let's just start one with uh you've got
a very unique multi-disciplinary
background maybe walk us through when
somebody says to you what the hell do
you do all day how do you answer like
what is what is the way that you
evaluate both the disciplines and kind
of experience and skill sets but also
your personal interest
i just try to understand human nature
it's really pretty simple um i've been
doing this thing called evolutionary
psychology for about 30 years
and so i'm a psychology professor at
university of new mexico
and my research
is pretty it's pretty broad you know
i have like a limited attention span so
i like to work on topics for a few years
at a time and so i've worked on
a variety of stuff like
human sexuality and mate choice and how
we fall in love and how we choose our
partners
i've worked a bit on
individual differences like behavior
genetics and intelligence and
personality traits i've done a bit on
consumer behavior
and
you know after 30 years of kind of
studying human decision making i finally
finally got into crypto about a year ago
and that's that's my new passion we'll
see how long it lasts what what is so
interesting to you about bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies like why there's so
much stuff that you do that i find
fascinating everything from what i would
consider like traditional uh research
just around human decision making
behavioral economics and that stuff to
even more of the like what some people
consider the more controversial stuff
and viewing hey we live in this mad
crazy insane world
but cryptocurrencies like why is that
the thing that now you're so interested
in
i can i can sort of look at the crypto
space wearing a number of different hats
so one hat is just
as a behavioral scientist
what's going on with crypto it's an
exciting movement it's also
psychologically really confusing and
there's a lot of aspects of crypto that
are extremely counter-intuitive
like how do people think about
value and networks and security and
decentralization and
how do these protocols actually work
what's the kind of underlying game
theory of how do you get you know
consensus mechanisms that are
resistant to attack so there's kind of
this like psychology of of how people
understand crypto
another hat is just as an individual
investor
how do you face the very very steep
learning curve of trying to understand
what what the hell is this industry how
does it function
how do you distinguish
you know a good solid project from a
shitty meme coin
how do you kind of uh
work your way into the industry without
you know getting wrecked and losing
everything
and then
a third hat is just at a kind of social
and political and cultural level
what's going on with crypto how does it
challenge traditional
um finance and vested interests and what
are the full kind of cultural and
political implications so all three of
those um
are absolutely fascinating to me
and i love getting kind of red pilled by
new
you know human phenomena and i think
crypto
no matter what you think of it
as
um a movement or as a sort of investment
uh domain
is absolutely fascinating if you have
any interest in human nature or
psychology so let's start with a third
one first uh this idea of challenging
the establishment challenging the
incumbents whether they're just
financial firms uh or something much
bigger how do you think about evaluating
the current new technologies that we
have verse that like old legacy world
the funny thing about the old legacy
world
um the way that fiat currency works the
way that banking works is
it's really hard to understand the
legacy world
until you understand crypto
right because you just take the legacy
finance world for granted you just kind
of think that's the state of nature
obviously that's how capitalism and
finance and money and and pensions
should work
because there's no contrast there's no
alternative once you get a serious
contrast
a sort of alternative system then you
can start to kind of pick apart the
legacy system and understand
oh my gosh like here's banking here's
why wall street and banking have certain
kinds of lobbying here's why they have
certain kinds of political influence
and um
here's
why it's oppressive and kind of
constraining to people so i kind of felt
like crypto blew my mind about that
because
you know i've like worked in an
economics department for four years at
university college london
surrounded by people who do behavioral
economics work and in a way they
kind of know less
about the existing finance system than
even
kind of crypto newbies who've just read
a little bit like you know the bitcoin
standard or watched your show for you
know a few hours
and so when you think about that uh
maybe difference in education is it
because they are incentivized not to
understand so if you're sitting at an
academic institution whether you're
sitting in an elected official position
or in an appointed position uh let's
just call them kind of the academics and
theorists if you will rather than the
market participants is it a you're
disincentivized from learning is it you
don't need to so you're almost
complacent or do you actually understand
and uh you're better off not letting on
the fact that you understand because
that would then the game would be up if
you will
i think it's mostly just you're
surrounded by uh group think you're
surrounded by like-minded people who've
all taken the same
you know
200 level macro economics courses that
say this is how money should work this
is how you should manipulate the money
supply
in order to deal with financial crises
or promote growth or manage unemployment
and if you get you know a's in
macroeconomics and then you become like
a finance person or a banker or an
economist you figure
well i got the seal of approval from
traditional econ i must know what
i'm talking about and everybody around
me thinks the same way
so
stepping outside of that is very
difficult because you're you're subject
to immense
um professional pressures to kind of
conform to that world view
if you start talking about alternatives
you know everybody you know thinks
you're kind of crazy and also you've got
heavy professional disincentives not to
make noise about that because
you know you it'll limit your career
options for example if you're an
economist who wants to like advise
governments about things you kind of
have to buy into like the imf fiat world
view about these things
when you start to look at the behavioral
economics of all of this uh there's a
lot of talk of game theory right of of
kind of bitcoin is inevitable uh people
have to adopt it at some point and i
think when people were saying that in
2010 2011 2012 that was like a a pipe
dream and even the people that were
involved in were like yeah i mean we
kind of believed it but you know that
was kind of crazy idea
now it seems to be playing out we've got
individuals in now we've got financial
institutions we're starting to see some
public corporations we have one nation
state that's made illegal tender and
really started to kind of uh embrace it
is this
using history as like a guide
of course this was going to happen of
course this is like the natural
progression of something or are you
surprised by this given kind of the the
mental models and experience that you
have in some of these disciplines
the game theory here is really
complicated so there's kind of one level
of game theory which is at the protocol
or consensus level of how do you keep
any given protocol like you know bitcoin
or ethereum or cardano resistant to
specific kinds of attacks
but then there's
a larger kind of political game theory
which is
how do you get enough
buy-in from
existing power structures including
regulators and nation states
so that they can't mess it up
so that
for example enough politicians are
personally invested in bitcoin or have
family wealth in bitcoin that
they no longer have the personal or
political incentives to attack it really
hard
as far as i can tell there's a lot more
game theory applied to kind of how do we
keep you know bitcoin safe from a 51
attack
ban there is game theory applied to that
larger political issue
um or the issue of like
the sort of intergenerational thing of
how do you convince rich boomers to
actually invest in crypto rather than
just young people who don't have any
money or middle-aged you know guys like
me you have like a little bit of money
and a little bit of understanding
so
when you're doing game theory and you're
thinking
how do we make this
um
crypto protocol resistant to attack
the attacks can come from many many
levels it could be
political regulation
it could be a kind of cultural level
attack like if crypto somehow got
associated with certain
um
taboo beliefs
right if if it was smeared by
association with certain
um
unacceptable cultural associations
then nobody would want to own crypto
because the social cost would be too
high
so when you're thinking about the game
theory you have to be
very inclusive in thinking
what are all the possible vectors of
attack that could mess up the crypto
industry
when you think about let's take the
oldest americans the people who have the
most capital uh kind of that boomer
generation
what would be your way to get them into
this get them familiar with it and get
them to adopt like what is the uh game
theoretical way to say okay let's get
the people who have the most money and
or have the most experience let's
convince them that this is the future
i think that's that's like literally the
10 trillion dollar question because the
amount of assets that people over 60
have is
fast it's enormous and if
they started allocating even
you know five or 10 percent
into crypto it would be an absolute game
changer and it would kind of lock in
crypto
financially and politically
in a big way
i think
you know old people tend to be
avoidant of novelty and avoidance of
risk so the big things you have to
overcome are
crypto is really really confusing and
counterintuitive at a psychological
level
i've worked in a number of different
fields and i've learned about a lot of
new fields in my sort of career as a
researcher and what i've noticed is
if you're like new to an academic field
the fields that are easiest to learn
about
are those that have taken pains
to reach out and write like
popular accessible books that are kind
of pitched at a medium level of
understanding and i think that's what's
missing in crypto
what you have on the one hand is a lot
of populist outreach where like it's
easy to watch youtube videos by crypto
youtubers
kind of doing a surface level
you know analysis of like here's this
new token and here's the technical
analysis of it and you should buy it
and on the other hand there's the
incredibly deep technical details like
read this white paper learn how to run a
node you know figure out exactly how the
consensus protocol in the tokenomics
works that's really hard what you're
missing
is the kind of middle ground where you
have
sort of books or blogs or videos that
explain things in a pretty
pretty serious but pretty accessible way
to reasonably smart boomers
who have vast amounts of money
but they're not going to invest in
something just because some 25 year old
youtuber says it's good
so i think that's what's missing we need
a lot more material
at that kind of medium level of like
it's serious and it's accurate but it's
accessible to people who didn't do phds
in computer science
so when you start to think about uh that
group getting in those are also the same
people that end up uh controlling a lot
of the wealth at financial institutions
pension funds endowments foundations
like like the whole institutional asset
management world all the way up to
sovereign wealth funds is the thought
process that once you start to kind of
uh red pill or orange pill uh the boomer
generation then all of a sudden all
those institutions they start to go kind
of all in on this industry because they
do it first personally and then they
move their institutional assets
yeah i think
if you orange build a significant
percentage of boomers and they started
going to the financial advisors and
their pension funds and you know if they
have a family office if they have a
significant wealth if the family offices
start talking to the banks and they go
why can't we get exposure to this
industry
come on
you've got a fiduciary duty to allow us
to invest in it why aren't you doing
that
um i think
that's when the existing finance
industry has to start taking
this seriously
you know if you've got a bunch of 30
year olds
sort of writing emails to their banks
saying you know i'm frustrated that
if you guys are making it hard to invest
in crypto banks don't care
if you've got a bunch of boomers um
calling up their
kind of um financial advisors going why
don't you know anything about this
you have a professional duty to learn
more
that's an enormous source of leverage
because it's not just in the financial
interest of the
financial advisors to learn about it
it appeals to their their kind of
professional ethos
i really should respond to my clients
you know these orange peeled boomers
and learn about this stuff
and i think that's one possible path to
to serious mass adoption and kind of
integration of
legacy finance and crypto
when you start to look at the legacy
system uh you had this great tweet at
one point around uh fiat currency and uh
it just makes me laugh when i read it he
said fiat currency is the
intergenerational ponzi scheme your
great grandkids won't thank you for
buying into it explain this more
well i try to take a very long-termist
perspective you know i'm pronatalist i
think about uh future generations i i'm
concerned about the long-term viability
of civilization
um i'm interested in kind of existential
risks to humanity and
civilization so i'm always thinking
how will this play out in future
generations
and even young people kind of understand
oh if i have kids and grandkids i will
love them and i will care about them and
i will become more interested in their
future
but somehow that
future orientation that long-termism
doesn't really translate
that well into a lot of
financial decision-making or into
motivation to to learn about how does
money work how does finance work
so when i do these tweets i'm kind of
trying to nudge people to think about
how can i connect my my family's
future real life interests
to
you know how i bother to spend my time
learning about new topics
and
i think you know every dad every mom
every grandparent has a kind of
duty to their family legacy
to get serious in terms of learning
about
fiat versus crypto
another piece of this that i feel like
is tangentially related is we obviously
have the fiat currencies they're being
devalued that ends up leading to this
whole debt and the monetization of the
debt and uh kind of backed our central
bankers and politicians into a corner
they have no uh other choice other than
to go ahead and continue to do this so
that brings up the question how they
fund it and it always feels good to say
well we're gonna take money from rich
people right uh and so specifically
around this uh idea of unrealized
capital gains uh you have a tweet that
says unrealized capital gains one they
aren't gains and two or none of the
government's business uh i tend to agree
with you but walk me through how you
evaluate um kind of
that entire conversation and like it
feels almost like of course we should
expect them to have the conversation but
my general take is that it's never going
to actually be implemented you know at
least in the current form that they're
talking about
there there's a couple of key problems
here one is just innumeracy people don't
understand numbers and they don't
understand like how much wealth rich
people have which is vast
but it's not vast enough to cover
federal spending for very long
okay so there's just a failure of
what's called scope sensitivity
understanding the relative scope of like
billions versus trillions versus tens of
trillions
so people are just delusional
in thinking that like
you know elon musk could just allocate a
tiny percentage of his his income and
like solve world hunger
right that's not how the math works
so
you know the failure of public schools
to teach numeracy is one issue there's
also just kind of economic vengefulness
and and bitterness and resentment where
like some people are very rich and i'm
not and so i want to take them down
and there's a deep-seated
kind of primal
human nature aspect to this that you
know when you live in little clans if
there's like some
domineering
narcissistic alpha male everybody wants
to get together and kind of take them
down
right and reduce their their arrogance
and that plays out politically in the
kind of um
politics of economic resentment
but it just doesn't work practically you
can't tax the rich
enough to actually pay for every the
entire welfare state of the sort that
like
um certain political parties are
advocating the math just doesn't work
when you start to think about the
digital world the digital world to me uh
is a uh replication of the analog world
right for the most part and when we talk
about human behavior or one of these
ideas that you talk a lot about of like
evolutionary consumer psychology
is the digital world different like are
people going to act differently think
differently
or kind of execute certain actions
differently in the digital world or is
it actually a carbon copy of what we've
seen for thousands and thousands of
years of human history it's now just
gonna get carried out in like a digital
form
it's kind of hard to tell but
if i had to bet i would predict that a
lot of our our basic human preferences
and motivations will stay relatively
constant
and then they'll just be manifest in all
these new digital ways for example
we seem to have an unquenchable desire
to kind of be attractive and to show off
our our status and our attractive traits
and to show off our intelligence to show
off our moral virtues and i wrote about
this in my book spent that that
translates in the consumer world to
predicting kind of what we buy why we
buy it why we love branded goods
why we associate so closely you know
certain brands with certain kinds of
values and personal attributes like
oh i'm into apple so i'm like
open-minded and progressive and liberal
whereas those people who are into like
microsoft are more
conservative and close-minded
and the way this will play out i think
in the digital world like let's say
virtual reality or meta or whatever
is basically like you you'll take human
instincts for
being attractive and showing off
like 100 thousand years we might have
put red ochre iron oxide pigments all
over our body and made body
ornamentation now it'll be buying
um nfts and digital avatars that make us
look cool in virtual environments
but i think the underlying
um human motivations and kind of
instincts
aren't likely to change that much
i could be wrong but
you know if i was making financial bets
i would say
this this desire to signal who you are
and why you're cool in the digital realm
that's just a limitless um
motivation that people have and it's
very easy to monetize it is it fair to
say that uh there is an entire investing
strategy that has legitimacy where you
essentially just look at how do people
want to flex or show that social status
in a digital realm and if you can
basically get to those items or those
things first then uh it is likely that
you will make money um which feels like
in the legacy world that's not
necessarily the case like if i go buy a
ferrari before you buy one uh actually i
lose money right because it's
depreciating asset in this new digital
world it feels to some degree if there's
a ferrari equivalent and i get there
before somebody else the financial gain
is different it's not just about can you
flex in for social status but there's
also like a financial aspect
yeah exactly i think
i i hadn't really thought about that
before but i think you're right if you
can find
bats on you know companies or protocols
that are providing ways that people can
flex
any of their traits that they might want
to show off to other people
and people can
send these signals in a way that's kind
of reliable and hard to fake
right this is what nfts did um once
enough people understand how nfts work
and how
ownership
of these digital assets
is reliable and is hard to fake
then i think this could easily become
kind of a major way that people kind of
show off
their their identity and their values
and their traits to each other
so this intersection of nfts and gaming
i don't fully understand it i'm not
personally invested in it but if i was
smarter and younger that's probably be
that would be where i would i would pay
a lot of attention
because that seems to be like the future
of social signaling
yeah i i tend to think that there's a
lot of people paid attention there and
uh and they agree with you joe what
questions do you have yeah so
you talk a lot about censorship and free
speech and things along those lines i
just wanted to get your opinion on kind
of where you think uh those issues stand
today in
america i'm a little pessimistic um
about the free speech situation because
you know i've been fighting for a free
speech in academia for a number of years
at least six the last six or seven years
pretty actively and and
both through social media and within you
know
the universities that i i work with
there seems to be a widespread
just ignorance about basic civics like
it seems like there's a couple of
generations that just didn't get taught
about the first amendment and what it
means and why free speech is important
and how it works
and so
you know if you follow
the organizations that try to promote
academic free speech like foundation for
individual rights and education fire or
heterodox academy
you just keep meeting the same kind of
ignorant
opposition again and again and again
people just don't understand
how free speech works how constitutional
law works
so i'm kind of pessimistic that
it's
that you can kind of re-educate
a couple of generations that kind of
don't get it
and don't value it
um i think what it'll take
is
alternative institutions i think it'll
take farsighted rich people and
billionaires establishing new
universities
new media companies new ways of sharing
ideas
hopefully you know if we have enough
school choice new k-12 um
schools and school franchises that have
different uh values that are a little
more libertarian and less
a little less preachy
john what questions you have yeah
jeffrey nice to meet you thank you for
coming on um i'm curious can you talk
about like the psycho
psychological aspect of investing in
kind of the shift that boomers have
traditionally saved and then this
younger generation as millennials are
investing can you just talk about that a
little bit
i mean one big difference for me was
just
becoming comfortable with volatility
right
you know like my academic pensions
invested mostly in index tracking funds
it kind of like s p 500 oh it goes up a
little bit down a little bit
the kind of daily fluctuations are like
typically within a couple percent
then you get into crypto and it's like
oh my god i gained
50k last night and i lost 80k this
morning and
what the hell that's extremely scary
the first few months
and then you kind of get desensitized to
the volatility after a while
so i think um
you know to attract boomers it's almost
like you need to convince them to kind
of
just put a tiny amount of money
into these new volatile assets just a
tiny amount and kind of play with it and
kind of track it for a while and get
desensitized
before the stakes are high
right just have kind of a pretend fund
that you're playing around with on
whatever coinbase pro kraken and
and
get used to
this completely new way of investing
because it really is
you know to anybody over like age 40
extremely scary
to see your kind of net worth
fluctuating
this much
and so
we have this concept of habituation in
psychology where you're just kind of
exposed to a new environment and you
have to kind of get used to it
um
and it's very hard for young people to
understand how
alarming
that kind of volatility or that kind of
novelty is so i think we have to just be
more welcoming and also a lot more
reassuring
one thing i worry about is that you get
a kind of bitcoin maximalism or kind of
crypto preachiness that says
yo bro if you can't stand the volatility
get out of the kitchen
it's kind of macho posturing that's
flexing that's saying i can handle the
volatility older people can't
that makes me better
that's a terrible message and it's not
going to actually lead to mass adoption
agree when you look at that message
around uh what do you think the better
message would be
i think the better message would be
just
honesty about
you know
the fact that this is a scary industry
and the volatility is scary and it's
complicated and it's hard to understand
and it's it's technically intimidating
and if you're used to dealing with a
legacy finance system
that took most people kind of decades to
master before they even understood a
little bit about how does the stock
market work how does my pension work
um
it's very tempting if you know
a moderate amount about crypto to kind
of
show off that knowledge and to kind of
forget
how
intimidating the industry is to newbies
so
i think you can personalize this a
little bit you know if you're if you're
ever like making youtube videos or
tweeting about crypto
to imagine you're
communicating with like an aunt or uncle
who's kind of crypto skeptical doesn't
know much about it how would they react
to your your video or your tweet would
it entice them
to learn more would it make them think
ah
it's a little scary but these people are
welcoming
they'd be open to me joining their their
weird little cult you know or is it
off-putting is it sort of like oh i
don't want to get involved with it
because it's a bunch of kind of macho
[ __ ] who
who are just
doing their own weird thing and they're
not actually um
reaching out to me in a sort of
authentic and inclusive way one of the
things jeffrey that i think is um
misunderstood maybe in this entire thing
is the psychology at play right so when
we get these boom and bust cycles uh
retail investors more so than anything
else uh tend to succumb to both the fear
and the greed in the stock market
there's lots and lots of computers
playing against computers and so it's a
little bit different it's not true kind
of market psychology at play um but what
we see in uh bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies is that we get these
massive bull markets and then these
drawdowns over time that volatility will
likely subside somewhat uh as just more
people come in there there's uh kind of
less of illiquid supply etc but until
that occurs is it fair to say that the
price of these assets and the movements
are essentially a proxy or an indicator
for fear and greed and like that's a
that's one way to evaluate prices
relationship to the psychology of the
of the investors in the market
yeah totally i mean you know
crypto industry as we all know is highly
sentiment driven and it's
it's emotional and it's heard psychology
now has it helped me very much
having worked in psychology for 30 years
and studied all this stuff
it didn't really it didn't help me that
much
as a newbie investor
because like i've taught human emotions
courses for decades i've studied human
decision making for decades
but when when you've got skin in the
game when you've got your own skin in
the game
you have to kind of relearn all these
messages
in the abstract you can know
well uh buy low sell high when everybody
else is is greedy i should be fearful
and vice versa
but actually implementing that with
discipline and self-awareness
is really really hard
and
so there's kind of a gap between
knowing the psychology and the abstract
versus
practicing
you know implementing it and and
understanding it so
should crypto investors learn more
psychology should they read more
psychology books maybe
but
just time in the market in a sense is is
your best mentor
you shouldn't necessarily start out
pouring your whole life savings into
this industry because
then
if a bubble pops and you lose 80 percent
you will never come back into it
you'll be like
writing it off forever
so i think it's very important for for
crypto outreach and lobbying and
influence
to kind of warn newbie investors
uh
here are the pitfalls and here's how not
to succumb to the fear and greed and of
course there's there's a lot of people
including you who are very good at at
these warnings but i think
we just have to keep it up and
remember
how tough it is for newbie investors to
confront that kind of volatility
and to kind of
keep them safe
and
and
help remind them that
there's a lot of crowd psychology here
and if you just stick with it hopefully
in a few years
volatility will
will be a little bit reduced and these
asset values will be kind of fairly
priced in relation to their actual use
cases and and what they're actually
doing in the world
as a psychologist who understands uh so
much of this and understands consumer
behaviors uh when we look at what i
think most people would label as the
most insane versions so uh dogecoin
shiba inu etc we see these absolute
massive increases in prices and then we
just see massive drawdowns in those
prices how do you evaluate what's going
on there and like what is pulling people
in to participating in these things is
it pure profit or is there something
else driving their participation
i think the meme coins are fascinating
and i've actually been thinking about
writing a paper on sort of evolutionary
psychology of meme coins it's it's
partly
pure financial speculation and kind of
gambling and
you know all the usual like fomo and oh
it's gone up 10x it'll go up another 10x
i'll be rich
but it's also partly an expression of
identity and enthusiasm and interest and
like
you know there's so many people out
there who are kind of like
big elon musk fanboys so whatever elon
supports
you kind of want to be on team elon and
so you want to like buy into whatever
he's tweeting about
not necessarily because you think it's
going to make you rich
but because
people are willing to spend a lot or
even risk a lot
to identify with a particular
set of values or a celebrity um
some kind of icon
and so it's almost like
[Music]
you're kind of paying a tithe to a
church that you believe in
or it's like donating to a favorite
political party
not the people buying you know
dogecoin are
consciously doing that but i think
they're getting a lot of subjective
value out of feeling like
i'm on team doge and
that's part of me and i'm willing to
like spend 100 bucks or whatever i
invest if i'm up
you know gen z college student
to kind of be part of that little
subculture and to and to buy into it in
a
in a in a real way
when you also look at other aspects of
our society so it's meme coins is one
piece of it but when you start to look
at stocks
also you see gamestop amc i'm assuming a
lot of the same things are playing out
there um is this due to the rise of like
social media platforms like the reddits
the twitters of the world
or is this something that was always
there it was just on a smaller scale and
private conversations and now that uh
it's kind of being thrust forward the
media is actually pouring gasoline on
the fire because they're the ones who
are saying oh look at this reddit forum
which then leads to people joining the
reddit forum and people feeling like oh
i'm getting legitimacy i'm getting
validation for participating in this and
therefore i need to almost uh play the
part i need to lean into it even more
because the more that we lean into this
the further the coin or the stock goes
the further the coin of the stock goes
the more they talk about it in the
legacy world the more it validates what
we're doing
yeah i think
you know if
if you imagine maybe 19th century
investors like victorian era
guys who have a little bit of money
hanging around in the gentleman's clubs
in new york or philadelphia
and talking about what stock they should
invest in which railroad should they
support or which steamship line right
there'd be little bubbles of enthusiasm
like oh we should support union pacific
because
that to us represents you know the
future progress of america and and
colonizing north america and that's
something we can buy into and i'm sure
there was a lot of emotional appeal
in a lot of those investment decisions
150 years ago
but now the scale of social media and
the reach and you know millions of
people getting involved
in the same psychological dynamics
rather than just
you know a few rich guys and little
gentlemen's clubs
it just amplifies the
the speed and the volatility and the
kind of intensity of the market
yeah what's fascinating to me is you get
um a younger generation that has bought
into these memes whether they're stocks
coins whatever uh but i always say that
like berkshire hatha hathaway was the
original meme stock right it has a whole
generation of people that bought into it
there's this like jesus and disciple
mechanism where warren buffett has uh
literally a playbook a bible for value
investing people go on mecca to omaha
every year to go and see and and get
face time uh and to kind of get
indoctrinated into it and they literally
talk about the experience as
life-changing and you know all this kind
of crazy stuff now the legacy media
especially the financial world doesn't
talk about berkshire hathaway as a meme
stock
but
what's the difference between berkshire
hathaway and gamestop like sure they're
different stocks
but there's a lot of similarities there
i'd actually there's more similarities
than differences when it comes to
psychology and the relationship that the
holders of the stock have with each
other rather than the underlying
fundamentals right the fundamentals are
different but there is a lot of
psychology similarities it seems like
i think that's a pretty astute insight
actually because
with the boomers
there is this kind of iconography of
like the sage of omaha and
you know
this kind of
solid sober you know older figure who
kind of lives a little bit frugally and
does like i'm gonna find you value
investments and it's for the long term
and it's generational and dynastic
wealth so trust me
um
so there's a little bit of you know cult
around that just like those kind of the
the cult around elon musk
i think it's extremely important for the
crypto industry to understand the
psychology of those berkshire hathaway
investors
for example how do we figure out how to
reframe
good crypto protocols as
legit long-term value investing
rather than kind of emphasizing the
quick gains in volatility
and i think there are ways to do that
but you have to figure out
um
you know
what are the
the the sort of um
the tropes and the metaphors and the
language that were used to convince
berkshire hathaway investors to invest
and to stick with them
and then how can we kind of appropriate
some of those in the crypto industry to
appeal to the boomers
who are used to that kind of value
investing concept
but who don't see a lot of um
you know crypto youtubers
connecting
here's how you know investing in bitcoin
or ethereum or whatever
is actually similar to value investing
does warren buffett run a cult that's
one of my biggest questions like to me
when you start looking at these meme
coins or meme stocks uh there's a ton of
people who would say bitcoin's a cult
right i disagree but that's what they
would say a lot of people would say hey
dogecoin is a cult they'll say that
gamestop is a cult they'll say amc is a
cult does that mean berkshire hathaway
shareholders are a cult and therefore
like warren buffett runs a cult or is
there some way to decipher between no
this is group think this is
psychological kind of buy-in and comfort
to some degree and people are choosing
to participate they want to feel part of
a group but it's different than a cult
like how do you think about where is the
severity of this and how do you describe
uh what these meme stocks or coins have
versus what people i think have as a
traditional thought process of like what
a cult is
i think the crucial difference is you
know berkshire hathaway versus like
amway or any kind of other multi-level
marketing or or
pyramid scheme
berkshire hathaway is not just
investing in itself it's taking your
money and investing in other real
companies that have real assets and
dividends and
you know roi
so it's kind of the middle the middle
man
you're not just buying
berkshire hathaway token
that's only supported by you know
additional inflows from other investors
i think crypto needs to figure out
how do we convince crypto investors that
like
bitcoin or cardano or algrand or
ethereum aren't just investing in those
systems themselves
but those systems are middlemen between
you the investors and all the other
investors and companies and sources of
value
that are woven into the network and the
protocol
so i think you have to emphasize
like
how will these crypto protocols actually
connect to real life or real dividends
or real yields
and not just you know why are they a
good um
why are they just a better version of
amway right that's
so
it's kind of a shift in mindset where
you have to think
we're not just investing in the crypto
industry as an industry we're investing
in it as a way to connect all the other
industries out there
that will start playing in crypto rather
than in legacy finance
when you look at the financial markets
is there a world where um
people psychologically are being driven
to buy assets simply as a middle finger
to the system like to some degree that
was the narrative around gamestop that
was a narrative around amc and things
like that it's like oh uh gamestop there
was a short squeeze opportunity people
were buying it because literally they
wanted to take down wall street and like
i i don't know if that's true or not if
that's actually why people were doing it
but that narrative definitely has
persisted that like there's an entire
generation of people who saw their
parents get burnt by the global
financial crisis they you know basically
held this uh uh underlying burning
feeling towards this one industry and
now every chance they get they try to
stick it to the man in uh doing this
with like financial warfare is that how
you evaluate it or is that just like a
nice story but doesn't really have a lot
of kind of substance from a
psychological standpoint
oh my gosh i think there's a huge amount
of that i mean the whole initial
you know launch of bitcoin was very much
a libertarian middle finger to
to to fiat currency and to government
control of the money supply and so forth
and
look if people are willing to like give
up a year of their lives to like
campaign for some political candidate
who they passionately believe in
or to do
um
you know give ten percent of their
income to the mormon church just because
they believe in the church
you better believe people are willing to
make investment decisions partly on
kind of
political signaling grounds where
they're like
making some investment decisions
you know to signal to others to their
their spouses to their friends their
co-workers
these are my beliefs and i put my money
where my my mouth is or they're
signaling to themselves to kind of
reinforce their own identity like i'm a
libertarian and therefore i should be
buying crypto
um and they're willing to you know take
significant personal risks to do this
kind of
uh political
signaling i think for
the crypto industry as a whole to
succeed it'll be extremely important for
it not to be too closely identified
with any particularly narrow
set of political beliefs because then
it'll just alienate everybody who
doesn't share those beliefs
yeah
it's fascinating when you start to
think through
so much of the psychologies what's
driving this which yes that makes sense
kind of from a legacy standpoint but now
i not only can make my own individual
decisions but i can turn around and with
the click of a couple of buttons i can
tell
tens of people hundreds thousands tens
of thousands hundreds of thousands even
sometimes millions of people
this is what i'm doing this is why i'm
doing it and then there's kind of the
element of some people will follow
because elon musk did something some
people will follow because some great
investor on wall street did something
and so if you bring it all the way back
to bitcoin when paul tudor jones and
stanley druckenmiller came out and said
hey we're going to put bitcoin in our
portfolios or we already have
to me
that was more important than like
90 of the other stuff that had happened
only because now you have two people
that all these folks on wall street
looked at as these great traders are
great investors and they just remove
career risk even if everything went to
zero all these people in washington well
paul titor jones did it so like you know
he's smart
and he just reminds you that like humans
are humans right like we can put on the
suits and ties and play the game and
like oh this whole charade but at the
end of the day we all have this like
human hierarchical structure that we
follow and the psychology takes over and
we are incredibly uh
you know um kind of exposed to
succumbing to the fear the greed and uh
kind of that group think that uh you
know people warn you about over and over
again it feels like
i i think that point about career risk
is absolutely
crucial if you can convince enough
financial advisors that
you know other respected financial
advisors are
getting serious about crypto
then you're no longer the odd man out
who's sort of the you know the wacky um
cryptocultist you're simply following
the most respected and most successful
people in your your industry
so i think
you know celebrity finance
um
gurus and famous people on wall street
getting into it that's important but
also can you imagine what would happen
if like billy eilish or some other
pop culture icon came out strongly in
favor of any particular crypto project
right that would immediately have a
massive impact in terms of
sort of millennial and gen z investing
so i think
outreach to
you know wall street icons is important
but i also think crypto should
pay quite a bit a bit of attention to
just outreach to
um
pop culture celebrities
and you know hollywood actors and
musicians and stand-up comedians and
the people who actually
have enormous influence even if they're
not you know
finance experts
that's where
that's where the cultural power is
you guys have any other questions
no thanks for coming on jeffrey jeffrey
i could talk to you for hours man this
is like i'm fascinated uh as i said a
couple times now around
when you unpack this when you understand
what's happening
it's easy to see how there are some
folks who prey on this stuff and then
there's some folks who become uh kind of
experts at commanding it and like one of
the things that um there's a book uh i
don't know if you've read this but it's
called richer wiser happier william
greene wrote this book and he basically
goes and talks to 25 30 different of the
best investors in the world and he talks
them about how did you make your money
how do you have your investment process
what's your portfolio look like uh how
do you actually balance work and
investing with your your home life etc
and one of the things that you find is
the best investors in the world they
have very small concentrated portfolios
they do not have 250 stocks that they
got to keep track of and everything they
actually sit on their hands and don't do
a lot they just buy great assets hold
them for a long time
and on top of that
they almost never had special access to
the deals so they literally went in the
public stock market for example and and
bought it
and so one of the things that blew my
mind was if you ask somebody like a
charlie munger charlie owns like three
stocks he was berkshire hathaway he owns
costco and i forget what the other one
is and people are like what do you mean
you own costco he's like well and he
walks you through the evaluation of it
or whatever he goes and i've owned it
for years and i don't plan to sell it
and so to some crazy degree you have uh
an entire generation of people that are
growing up
with all these platforms that
there's flashing lights and bings and
dings and this and like it's like like
it almost feels like a video game
but that is the exact wrong environment
to emulate what the best investors in
the world have been doing for decades
that has worked
and so you know my brother john is he's
25 years old and he said to me and i've
talked about this on the show a million
times he said to me once none of my
friends invested in anything unless they
think it's gonna go up 10x
right
and it's like that sounds great but like
how much of that is because they feel
like you know fiat currency i can't get
ahead how much of that is because of the
tools that they're using make them feel
like it has to go up a lot right and
there's you know big green numbers and
and all that and how much of it is just
you're just a young person you'll have a
lot of experience and like that was
happening you know 50 years as well i
don't know what the answers are but it
does feel like there has been a very
material shift in uh the way that young
people are thinking about this stuff
yeah and it's it's sad because they they
kind of are acting as if life is really
really short you know i'm i'm 56 and
like if i'd
invested seriously starting at age 20
and even if i was getting like
five or eight percent
a year compounded i'd be extremely rich
by now if you're getting
2x per year
and consistently for decades you're
gonna be in awesome shape so
i think it's
you're absolutely right it's it's
important for young crypto investors to
pay attention to what were older wiser
investors doing that really really
worked consistently over time
and don't don't emulate everything
they're doing don't necessarily buy
costco stock
but adopt that mindset that you're
you're in it for the long term you're in
it for generational wealth you're in it
to be able to leave a legacy to your
grandkids
and
you know 10x gains every three months
um
they're not going to be sustainable
anyway i mean once crypto gets big
enough you know it's it's going to reach
an asymptote
and like all the world's assets are in
crypto it's not going to go up 10x after
that
so
patience
and
you know
wisdom and learning from older
generations of investors
they don't understand the technical
details of crypto they don't understand
fiat they don't understand crypto's
potential but they do understand the
right mindset for making sustained
long-term gains
where can we send people to find you on
the internet i've got your twitter
account here i'm going to drop the link
right now in the chat i highly suggest
people go follow you on twitter is there
anywhere else that you want us to send
people um i feel like you just have such
a clear way of thinking about this stuff
that people should absolutely follow you
or consume some of the other content
thanks i've got a website primalpoly.com
and all my papers my books my research a
lot of my videos are are up there
and um
yeah i've written some books like the
mating mind and spent and uh
mate which is
dating advice for young single guys
um
so i've worked on a lot of a lot of
different stuff and so
but but yeah if you just follow me on
twitter
primalpoly you'll you'll get a sense of
my um my quirky view of the world
john you gonna get the book
yeah probably
i love it all right jeffrey listen thank
you so much for doing this again i
highly suggest people go check out the
the website primalpoly.com or follow him
on twitter i drop the link in the chat
make sure you go check them out and uh
we will definitely have to do this again
in the future i'm very excited to watch
you continue down the rabbit hole i've
seen a couple of tweets and i'm like oh
okay here we go uh so i feel like if we
do this again in the future you'll have
a ton of
thoughts on it but uh thanks so much for
coming on today
thanks it's been a pleasure